colombia vuelve a vivir fantasmas del
pasado en plena escalada de violencia
regiones como el cauca están en disputa
entre grupos armados por el control de
economías ilícitas y salidas al pacífico
allá se han producido miles de
desplazamientos forzados en las últimas
semanas en el municipio de argelia por
ejemplo hace unas semanas fueron
asesinados cuatro indígenas antes en
enero el concejo municipal había
abandonado en bloque por las amenazas
recibidas sin embargo el recuerdo de
otros tiempos se vivió en corinto con un
coche-bomba frente a la alcaldía que
dejó más de 50 heridos el pasado viernes
un conflicto que también se está
recrudeciendo en la frontera de 2000
kilómetros entre colombia y venezuela
con combates en los últimos días entre
el estado venezolano la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional e
insurgencias de las extintas farc ya hay
cerca de 5 mil desplazados según la
oficina de coordinación de asuntos
humanitarios la causa el abandono de los
estados de la frontera el libre flujo de
economías ilegales la corrupción y el
conflicto entre los estados de colombia
y venezuela
el presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro y su
colombiano iván duque han estado
lanzándose acusaciones cruzadas sobre
connivencia con grupos armados analistas
establecen cuatro causas del
recrudecimiento en colombia por un lado
el aumento de las economías ilegales con
el incremento del precio de la pasta de
coca del oro y la trata de personas
también la parálisis que vive la fuerza
pública y la ausencia de una estrategia
de seguridad en tercer lugar la inacción
del gobierno de iván duque en cumplir
los acuerdos de paz y por último la
falta de un grupo dominante entre bandas
criminales impide un control pleno de
los territorios y el aumento de las
disputas entre disidencias de las farc
el ejército de liberación nacional
paramilitares y narcotraficantes